what I've come to believe is that God
dies in the place where one group of
human imposes its cues on others and God
is born in the place where humans and
God worked together to create a better
world
Bruce Feiler thank you very much
Ron powers wrote about Mark Twain's
Missouri childhood in dangerous waters
now he considers the full life of the
man born Samuel Clemens in the context
of America during the latter half of the
19th and early 20th centuries he spoke
about the new biography in Manchester
Vermont for 50 minutes it is my pleasure
to welcome Pulitzer Prize winning writer
and Emmy award-winning critic Ron powers
Ron is with us to present his new book
Mark Twain a life it's the first
compelling biography of 20 in decades he
traces the passions achievements
friendships feuds romances and crushing
sorrows of the man who created Tom
Sawyer Huckleberry Finn and who
encountered nearly every major figure of
the of the 19th and early 20th centuries
Ron powers has given us a biography that
illuminates the full public and private
saga of the man whose life was in many
ways his greatest story and it was
unparalleled impact on America then and
now with the support of the Mark Twain
project in Berkeley California Ron has
drawn on thousands of Twain's letters
and stunning candid journal entries many
of which only recently discovered and
quoted for the first time I grew up as I
said before when I was trying to get you
to all sit in the front I grew up is the
son of a Baptist preacher who was also a
Baptist missionary in the Philippines
and I actually first heard of Mark Twain
before I heard about Tom Sawyer where
Huckleberry Finn because Mark Twain was
one of the most outspoken critics of
American imperialism in the early 20th
century under the McKinley
Administration when the United States
graciously freed the Philippines from
the Spanish and then crushed a peasant
rebellion where they killed 250,000
civilians in an attempt to then make the
United States colony of course we didn't
really call the are colonies colonies
but they were in fact that this was
something that was taught in every
Philippine school where I grew up and
something that is still not taught in
American schools to American children
and so Mark Twain was
in addition to being such an incredible
humorous and satirist and cultural and
social critic he he really understood
politics and the understood class
warfare and he understood the importance
of speaking up for people who were
crushed by power wherever it happened
and he's one of the most interesting
fascinating and complex characters that
I've ever encountered in the reading
that I've done and Ron has done an
exceptional job of bringing that to life
again in his new biography Ron has
studied and written about Mark Twain for
many years he is the author of 10 books
including dangerous water a biography of
the boy who became Mark Twain and a
co-author of two including the number
one New York Times bestseller flag of
our fathers and he's a fellow Vermonter
who lives in Middlebury who came down
here by oxen cart to be with us tonight
so please welcome and I guess the guys I
say sometimes since we're on TV tonight
for c-span let's shed all of our New
England reserve and really welcome Ron
powers the Northshire bookstore Wow that
didn't sound like Vermont thank all of
you for coming exactly thank you for a
beautiful introduction I really
appreciate it and I appreciate being
here at Northshire books I haven't been
here since you renovated it it's just
beautiful I'm at the end of a national
tour and I found that there is no better
place in the world to be than at a book
store that was those were the highlights
of my tour not the radio interviews hey
Ron tell us about Mark Twain well he was
part of it and there wasn't the radio
study was the bookstores and there is no
more satisfying kind of bookstore to be
speaking at that an independent
bookstore and Northshire books is among
the jewels of independent bookstores in
this country and I'm very honored that
you invited me here tonight
and I I'm very honored that all of you
were able to tear yourselves away from
the World Series I noticed that some of
you didn't even have time to remove your
black and white Chicago White Sox body
paint and I'm really doing it you're
saying there will get a close-up of
these mark twain by the way was a
baseball fan he wrote a lot about
baseball and he worked it into some of
his novels and into his autobiography he
used to root for his home team the
Hartford Dark Blues which alongside his
good friend the Reverend Joe twichell
and the two of them once watched the the
the Dark Blues lose again 10 5 to the
visiting team that called itself the
Boston Red Stockings so so don't hold
that against me I wasn't there I didn't
know him personally baseball did figure
metaphorically and in fact in a lot of
his novels and sketches in the
collection that came to be known as
letters from the earth he imagines a
game as recorded by the biblical
character Methuselah and if that's for
me tell them to hold it and I'll call
back them here's here's Mark Twain doing
the thews alone doing a baseball game he
that bore the club did suffer the ball
to be flung at him diverse times but did
always bend in his body or bend it out
and so save himself whilst the others
spat upon their hands he at the same
instant endeavoring to destroy the
umpire with his bludgeon yet not
succeeding through grievous awkwardness
but in the fullness of time he was more
fortunate and did lay the umpire dead we
made a how the support writer his
baseball fever was actually quite well
known it was so well known that in fact
he was even when he was in residence at
his beloved Elmira summer
retreat where he had the gazebo on the
top of the hill where he wrote many of
his great novels summer July of 1887 he
was invited to join the umpiring crew
for a real baseball game between two
teams from the area the alerts and the
unions and he accepted this story the
fact that he was going to umpire the
game got nationwide attention in the
press and so did Mark Twain's conditions
that he laid down for unburying this
game his conditions were that he'd be
furnished with a chair a fan an umbrella
and the pitcher of iced water and he
laid down some other stipulations
including these that the umpiring crew
are not to be required to call balls and
strikes unless they choose very similar
to today players will not be allowed to
receive flowers while running the bases
the audience is required not to say hi
to members of either team who weigh over
200 pounds while such players are making
second base he also stipulated the
tricycles be barred as well as messenger
boys carrying the ball the last minute
mark twain decided that he would do his
umpiring from the grandstand
so no serious damage was done to this
game mark twain has had more than his
share of literary on players in the 95
years since his death in 1910 he's been
the subject of something like 40
biographies either full or partial
biographies and critical studies that
number in the tens of thousands he is
perhaps the most examined American who
ever lived except perhaps for Lincoln
who by the way is among the very few
prominent figures of the 19th and early
20th centuries that Mark Twain did not
meet although I think that the young
Sammy Clemens came within a few blocks
of Lincoln as he passed through
Springfield Illinois as a 17 year old in
this
of 1853 during that epic breakout of his
from his boyhood home of Hannibal
Missouri enroute to New York in
Philadelphia and finally Washington this
is an unknown journey largely but it
priests aged everything to come
he made it to Washington the following
February in a snowstorm and he thought
himself out in the visitors gallery of
the United States Senate just turned 18
where he idly watched some senators with
names like Stephen Douglas and William H
Seward debate the Missouri Compromise so
with all of these literary empires
having made their calls it's obvious
that anyone proposing to write yet one
more biography of this man has to
confront a very simple and very
formidable question why one more it's a
question that I've asked myself many
times believe me many times over the
past two or three decades as I grappled
with the allure and the dread of
tackling the life of my famous fellow
townsman from Hannibal Lord because I
felt I'd known the guy all my life and
in a way I have the earliest physical
object in my memory was the majestic
Mark Twain bridge but spanned the
Mississippi River looking like a big
metal dinosaur with its legs planted in
that riverbed it looked to me as a small
boy as though it had stood in that River
since the beginning of time which meant
that Mark Twain must have been around
for at least that long to have the
bridge named after him I saw his
silhouette on the backs of produce
trucks I went to the movies at the Tom
Sawyer theater and explored Mark Twain
cave and ate pork tenderloin sandwiches
at the Mark Twain dinette I passed up
the Mark Twain Fried Chicken and now you
could go to Hannibal and conclude your
day with a ride around town on the to
tooth plane
ronita I never made it to the engine
drill motel although I never gave up
hope
look the point is that he was always
there always in my field of vision an
awesome figure an unfathomable figure
known throughout the whole world but in
a certain way it was my friend
it's my homie and when I got old enough
to start reading his works I quickly
understood why the world celebrated him
and I started to feel that it was almost
my obligation to add my two cents worth
to the story of his life that was the
lure the dread was at least equally
compelling what if I screwed it up
what if the headlines over my the
reviews of my biography would say
Hannibal nating defies odds gets Twain's
life all wrong and a few of those reduce
actually have said that not many but and
besides even more than that there were
all of these other biographies out there
they started in 1920 and they have
continued a page through time present
all these umpires what can I possibly
add what could anybody possibly add to
this great Canon of scholarship and
biography of Mark Twain so I spent I
have spent most of my adult life very
successfully not writing Mark Twain's
biography but he never quite let me
alone just as my hometown of Hannibal
never quite let me alone the man in the
town they just they kept following me
around I found myself coming back and
back to Hannibal in my books I used the
town as a locale of several books I used
it as the grain of sand that showed the
universe that was America whether it was
theme park overkill
during his 150th birthday celebration or
the venue for senseless adolescent
killings by young undirected
adolescent boys with no past no future
an eternal time present living in a town
that it ceased to become a town become a
collection of dislocated venues
stitching one moment together with
another with methamphetamines as the
drug I had to go back and find out why
that happened and there the fact that
Hannibal called to me the way that
Hannibal always called to him that's
where the similarity ends I have no
fantasies that I'm channeling him or
that I can reincarnation of him or
anything like that but at some point I
finally began to examine what had been
written about him and whether I could
add anything I looked at the biographies
and I looked at the scholarship that
dealt with Mark Twain and I started to
realize that there was indeed something
to be added to these books all these
books on all these shelves and that
something was the life itself I became
fascinated as I read these books with a
certain attitude was kind of a point of
view a distancing point of view that
recurred again and again in the books
and the essays with titles like these
the ordeal of Mark Twain Van Wyck Brooks
1920 set the template for 95 years then
the spiritual tragedy of Mark Twain Mark
Twain's
wound Mark Twain and the novel the
double-cross of authority in bad faith
dynamics of deception in Mark Twain's
America dark twins impostor and identity
in Mark Twain's America catching ruin or
Mark Twain's
road to bankruptcy Mark Twain God's fool
now I want to be clear that I admire
many of these books and papers they
contain some of the best works of
criticism on any topic that has been
done in America great works of
scholarship many of them
just in Kaplan's great book of 1966 mr.
Clemens and Mark Twain which won the
Pulitzer Prize still ranks as one of the
great American biographies but you can't
get away from a certain tone certain
unsettling tone that that transforms
itself from one book to the next
it's a tone of skepticism almost of
suspicion as if the subject in question
requires a kind of forensic diagnosis
that's far more exacting far more
accusatory than is usually invested in
the literary figure now read on and I
discovered a kind of sub theme within
this critical diagnosis see if you can
discern it as I read you the following
titles inventing Mark Twain getting to
the Mark Twain the making of Mark Twain
who was Mark Twain as if an answer the
man who was Mark Twain these are works
that tend to psychologically separate
Mark Twain from Samuel Langhorne Clemens
they almost present Mark Twain as a kind
of life-size puppet carefully conceived
and constructed and performed by Samuel
Clemens the puppet that there's hardly
any resemblance at all to the shadowy
and vaguely sinister character who is
pulling the strings from behind the
curtain and I started to ask myself why
is this why this distance why this
suspicion why has the most expressing
the most representative writer in all
American literature in fact the
architect of the American voice as we
now use it why has this figure typically
been evoked in the pages of scholarship
and biography as a collection of
disembodied parts as an inventory of
symptoms as a writer who is interesting
not for his richness not for his
achievements
not for his enduring resonance with
readers of his own country but also in
England and Europe and South America and
Russia and in recent years now in Asia
thanks to some beautifully and lovingly
realized translations of his distinctly
American language into the language of
the Far East no he's not interesting
apparently for any of these but
interesting in so many important cases
for his flaws for his failure to measure
up for his masks and de sections and
subversions for his betrayal whether
real or imagined of our contemporary
standards of gender equality and racial
equality and literary structure and for
his terribly de classe insistence on
stooping to humor who the hell did Mark
Twain think he was Mark Twain or
somebody well as I continue to explore
this literature of what I call forensic
diagnosis I began to figure out why it
was so popular why it is so popular a
tool for dealing with Mark Twain at
least I have some theories one reason is
that he really seems to have asked for
it in a lot of ways that pen name Mark
Twain Twain twins duality split
personality light darkness good bad he
was practically a walking cry for help I
began to believe that if he'd stuck to
an earlier alias he used to call himself
Thomas Jefferson Snodgrass he stuck to
that we wouldn't have had a third as
many psycho biographies and I think
there are some other reasons I won't go
into them in detail but the advent of
post structuralist studies in the
mid-1980s which gave critics certain
diagnostic tools for sort of
disassembling an author in these works
that had not been available before very
seductive and very appealing to the
analytical mind and he was Exhibit A he
was the great white male they lit on it
then there is a kind of pervasive
academic distrust
that sometimes I think borders on
prejudice against humor as a literary
form is against a legitimate form of
expression and perhaps even I think
sometimes a little bit of jealousy
toward this unschooled untenured genius
who rose to greatness without ever
having to defend a dissertation or fill
out an application for a grant so here
is a kind of idiot savant and that is
pretty much the way he's been pigeon
holed and I'm going to let Mark Twain
have the last word about critics and
criticisms and under the MoveOn he says
I don't mind what critics say of me so
long as they don't tell the truth about
me when they descend to telling the
truth about me I consider that an unfair
advantage he also said that academic
language is like a snow flurry on a warm
sunny day every flake was distinct and
perfect but they melted before you could
grab enough to make a ball out of them I
think I agree with that and I'm not
going to stand here and admit to you are
you going to assassinate me it is a form
of compliment but okay you're right for
the New York Times buddy but I'm not
going to stand here I may not be
standing here at all and admit to you
that I have stooped low enough to tell
the truth about Mark Twain if I'm a
successful a sinner that I as I feel
that I am i standed the chance of
meeting in in the afterlife and heaven
for climate health of society and then
I'd have a lot of explaining to do but I
will tell you that in reading through
the vast body as Mark Twain biography
and scholarship I did become aware that
there was perhaps an opportunity to
contribute something fresh and that's
something as I said a few moments ago
was the life itself the epic life that
he lived the epic stride that he made
across the last half of the nineteenth
century
in the first decade of the 20th it was a
stride that took him back and forth
across the country to almost every
important city and around the globe and
that it not only produced his literature
which would be enough but it carried him
in an almost uncanny way and this was
among the greatest surprises as I did
this research it carried him again and
again and again to the epicenter of just
about every formative moment and the
development of the America that we know
aesthetic and artistic sure we know that
but also political and social and
economic and technological and
geopolitical I argue in the book that he
was there at the beginning of the
concept of an alternative newspaper in
Virginia City during the Civil War the
territorial enterprise that attracted
all of these kind of fugitives wild-eyed
poets and writers like Sam who were just
heading west somewhere else they'd
washed out Sam had washed out as a miner
he goes to this little paper on the side
of a mountain that happens to be sitting
on top of the Comstock Lode so it does
attract the town is attracting people
and he and the other guys he's with
began to develop a voice that is nothing
like the voice back east it is a
dangerous voice it is a tall tale
telling voice it's a voice that writes
hoaxes and has viewed some of the mocks
some of them real and it's a
truth-telling voice in its own moral way
it tells the truth at ground level the
truth of ordinary people speaking
ordinary language and that's what makes
it different from the high European
diction that America is still
worshipping back in Boston in
Philadelphia and the great centers of
the East addiction that has been
embraced by wonderful writers and
scholars named Emerson and Longfellow
and Holmes the writing incredibly
important works but they're speaking in
a voice that was inherited from the
classical languages Sam got the
invoice worked out in Nevada in
California and brought it back east and
changed everything but before he goes
back east he goes on to San Francisco
where he really does magnetize himself
really to the the center of a crowd of
people who are the great great
grandmother's and great-great
grandfather's of the counterculture of
the hippies of great poets like William
Burroughs and people like Jack Kerouac
and then Grace Slick and the Jefferson
Starship and Mario Savio at Berkeley
these are people who again are so far
away from a sense of having to report in
to the high gods that they're creating
an art based on dissent and
experimentation and a kind of controlled
madness and again something that is
profoundly true and very new and there
he is at the center he knows Bret Hart
he knows Adela Isaacs Menken he knows a
de Clare and he absorbs this and carries
it back and he never lets go of it
so he's at the founding moment not only
of our culture but of our counter
culture as well as as we have heard
earlier tonight and as well most of us
know he was the voice of
anti-imperialism in the last decade of
his life he walked down the gangplank of
the Minnehaha that had carried him back
across the Atlantic from ten years of
Exile in Europe because he was broke
from stupid investments page typesetting
machine he took an accounting of this of
the invasion of the Philippines of the
subjugation of the Philippine people and
he told the gaggle of reporters that
were always there always waiting for him
he looked at them and said I am an
anti-imperialist
he continued the American Eagle should
not sink its talons into any foreign
land
that was the most muscular the most
fearless of all of the voices that had
been timidly raised against imperialism
so far the Nation magazine had said
something like we do find it tremulous
in that these disputatious events have
Cameron Lili Lili I am an anti
imperialist he said and he went on to
write to the person sitting in darkness
which is still available and has been
resuscitated on the Internet in the days
of our own reckonings with imperialism
he wrote the United States of Lynch
Erdem about continuing lynchings going
on in his home state of Missouri an
essay that should erase any lingering
doubt about Mark Twain's moral stance
visa V Negroes they were not African
Americans yet they were hardly Americans
but they were still being hung and he
hated it and he wrote about it
he wrote about other colonial moves
around the globe these essays were
collected they were sort of suppressed
in his lifetime because his daughter and
his first biographer thought they were
against the image of the kindly
avuncular fellow telling tall tales
about little boys playing hooky and they
didn't surface until years after his
death and I think that has left the Gulf
in the American impression of who Mark
Twain was so I wanted this I wanted I
didn't want the last ten years to be his
deterioration and his failure and the
unfinished stories and the household
intrigues among his staff they were
trying to wrestle for control of his
legacy and it was pathetic
I wanted the public life and I wanted
actually I wanted the public life
throughout his career and I wanted to
hear him and I wanted you to hear him I
wanted you to hear his friends I wanted
you to hear the people who knew him and
truly understood him the people he loved
the people he hated his relatives his
fiancee and then wife Olivia his great
good friend William Dean Howells who
formed with Sam the most
beautiful friendship of the 19th century
has expressed in 40 years of letters on
his loopy brother Orion who he half
hated and half protected his daughters
Susie and Clara especially Jean died
before she could really express herself
in print about him
all of these people the friends the
enemies and sweethearts the editors the
inventors the presidents the literary
eminences the outlaws the quacks the
preachers the Tsar's the kings who were
there on stage with him and thunk formed
what I think of as his great supporting
cast and I had an access to this life
this life as lived that other
biographers have had and used some
extent but I think have not used as
fully and as evocatively as the man
deserves and that access is the Mark
Twain project at the University of
California at Berkeley one of the
world's great archival treasures
supervised by a wonderful scholar named
Robert Hurst who with his staff has been
added for 30 years collecting these
letters they have 12,000 of them now
from him into him
the letters are still coming in because
they think he wrote as many as 50,000
maybe a hundred thousand letters in
addition to all of the manuscript
writing he did sometimes one or two
lines the letters are there they come in
to the average of two or three a week to
the editors at the project so he's still
writing and they're still collecting it
and the scholarship that has involved
these letters and his notebooks and
journals the private Diaries he kept
that get us into his stream of
consciousness that got us into his dream
life he wrote he poured his soul into
his notebooks and Diaries and those are
the choices that I made I wanted to take
myself off stage get all of these
fascinating people on stage and put them
in motion and write a narrative of his
not a commentary about his life but a
narrative my idea being that if I did my
job which was to bribed you provide you
with the evidence and organize it and
assemble it and give it to you then you
would do your job as readers which is to
collaborate with me absorb that evidence
criticize it be skeptical enjoy it imbue
it with your own perspective and make of
it what you will
was he a wounded repressed victim of his
circumstances and tieran izing mother a
cold wife and a smothering friend named
Mary Fairbanks or was he a visionary
genius or was he both or neither was he
a manipulator of his public persona was
he a puppet master or were Sam Clemens
and Mark Twain the same person or does
it matter
was he a racist was he a man who lived
in terror of women was he gay was he a
substance abuser or was he the man who
wrote Adventures of Huckleberry Finn you
decide that's what the book is it's it's
a narrative of that great epic stride he
made and you're welcome to come along
for the ride I'm going to spend the rest
of my time just a few minutes just
giving you some examples of the voice
that I found that you don't many the
many voices inside this man that you
don't really get and a lot of the
available biographies his great the book
that established him of course was the
innocence abroad is that account of the
pilgrims who went to the Holy Land
aboard the steamer Quaker City to
worship at the feet of the gods and the
statues and the Sphinx and the pyramids
he didn't worship he satirized his
fellow pilgrims and came back and wrote
a revisionary masterpiece and I'm going
to show you the example an example of
what appeared in the final pages of the
innocence abroad as compared to what
originally appeared in his private notes
that he thought nobody would ever read
here's the official version it involved
they land on the Azores the first island
group before Europe they all come
running off the ship the young men spot
stable where they have saddled donkeys
for hire so the guys are going to go
native they run over rent the donkeys
jump on and pretty soon it's a stampede
and here's the formal version of it he
says as we came through town we
encountered squad of little donkeys
ready for use half a dozen of us mounted
the ungainly saddles and started it was
not a trot or a gallop or a canter but a
stampede with no Spurs necessary the
mule appears bang the donkeys with their
gold sticks and prick them with their
spikes and kept up a din and a racket
that was worse than bedlam itself blue
kurz donkey scampered zig zag crossed
the road and the others ran into him he
turned a corner suddenly and Blucher
went over his head and to speak truly
every mule stumbled over the two and the
whole cavalcade piled up in a heap
that's not bad but that's a sanitized
version here's what he wrote in his
notebooks remember he's talking about
donkeys the party started at 10 a.m.
Dan was on his ass the last time I saw
him and this time mr. foster was
following and mr. Haldeman came next
after foster mr. foster being close to
Dan's ass and his own ass being very
near to mr. Haldeman SAS after this
captain Bursley joined the party with
his ass and all went well till on
turning a corner of the road
a most frightful and unexpected noise
issued from captain burrs Lee's ass
which for a moment threw the party into
confusion and at the same time a
Portuguese boy stuck a nail into mr.
Foster's ass and he ran ran against Dan
who fell fell on his ass and then like
so many bricks they all came down each
and every one of them and each and every
one of them fell on his ass
that's the comic voice that's the voice
we know well we may not know that
particular version but we know the comic
voice the voice that says senators in
Washington whiskey is carried into the
Senate in demijohns and carried out in
demagogues that's wonderful wordplay
when he was told that his rich brutally
capitalistic benefactor Henry Huddleston
Rodgers when somebody told him that
Rogers his money was tainted he said
yeah it's quick as when he said yeah
Kate yours and taint mine so we know we
know the comic voice but I'm going to
let you hear the voice of the lover the
voice of the man who encounters this
beautiful daughter of the elmira
aristocracy ten years younger than he
he's back from the West with a sagebrush
still falling off of his clothes he's
wearing his muddy boots and he's got the
cigars and he's foul nobody like this
ever set foot in the Langdon household
before Sam did and the first chance he
had he proposed to Olivia and she turned
him down what a surprise
he went up to the room the guest room
where he was staying as a guest of the
Langdon's and he began the first of a
hundred and eighty four love letters
that he would write to her in the
ensuing year and they worked here's the
first one am i honored sister the
impulse is strong upon me to say to you
how grateful I am to you for the
patience the consideration and the
unfailing kindness which has been shown
me ever since I came within the shadow
for this roof I do not regret that I
have loved you still loved and shall
always love you I accept the situation
uncomplainingly
hard as it is of old I am acquainted
with grief
thirty-five
disaster and disappointment and so hints
forward I claim only that you would let
me freight my speeches to you with the
simply sacred love of brother there's a
sister write me something from time to
time texts from the New Testament if
nothing else occurs to you
it worked worked they're married and
it's a wonderful marriage and it
produces four children one of whom dies
at the age of two the daughters fulfill
20 happiest years of his life and he and
Lily remain devoted to one another until
her death in 1904 but his tone changes
after he's got her so now it's 1874
January of 1874 he's in London where
he's gone
to make a round of speeches and protect
his British copyright Livia's back home
and Hartford across the Atlantic and Sam
is really homesick he really misses
Livie and he's ready to board the
steamer that will take him home and he
writes her a letter just before he gets
on board says living my darling I want
you to be sure and remember to have in
the bedroom when I arrive a bottle of
scotch whiskey a lemon some crushed
sugar and a bottle of Angostura bitters
I love to picture myself ringing the
bell at midnight then a pause of a
second or two then the turning of a bolt
and who is it than ever so many kisses
than you and I in the bedroom I drinking
my cocktail and undressing and then to
bed everything giant happy as it should
be
still the lover he's still the adoring
husband he can just express it a little
more directly and they could he also I
hope I'm not he what I want you to hear
the voice of his indignation the voice
that he used in defending his idol
ulysses s grant after grants memoirs had
been published thanks to Mark Twain
grant was now dead the family was
rescued from bankruptcy but Matthew
Arnold over in London didn't care too
much for grants diction and he said so
in an essay that outraged Americans in
general and Mark Twain in particular Sam
gets even in a speech to the Army and
Navy Club of New York in 1887 he tells
the audience as they began to get
excited and then they punctuated his
words with applause he says when we
think of General Grant our pulses
quicken and the grammar vanishes we only
remember that this is the simple soldier
who all untaught of the silken phrase
makers linked words together with an art
surpassing the schools and put into
something a something which will still
ring to American ears as long as America
will last and bring the role of his
vanished drums and the tread of his
marching hosts what do we care for
grammar when we think of these
thunderous phrases unconditional and
immediate surrender I propose to move
immediately upon your works I propose to
fight it out on this line if it takes
all summer could have been speaking
about himself lean strong vernacular
words American in origin filled with
moral purpose and clarity I'm going to
stop with one more it's my favorite
quotation from him in all of his days
it's very short and it's again it's an
entry in his notebook that he never
expects to be published or read by the
public
he's on a train heading into Detroit at
night in the late 1880s he's been off
the lecture trail for about 11 years and
at that time American cities have been
electrically lighted no more gas lamps
he looks out and sees this and he just
jot some lines down in his notebook I
hope I can remember them he says I saw
for the first time a city where the
night was as beautiful as the day I saw
for the first time in place of salò
Twilight clusters of coruscating
electric Suns without visible means of
support which floated above the city and
cast a mellow radiance on the spires and
roofs and domes and far stretching
thoroughfares which lent the picture a
kind of beauty and dignity that one
captures in the essence of a dream
that's Sam looking out the window so the
next time you're stacked up over the
Burlington Airport take a closer look
see it the way sound so that's my fellow
townsmen and that's why I wrote the book
the way I did thank you for coming we're
going to take some questions and I would
I would ask a couple of things number
one only only ask one question per
person and secondly ask a question don't
make a speech and keep it very short so
that we can have time for a few
questions before we go downstairs to
sign books thank you here's one let's
wait for the microphone now everybody
those of us that have identity with our
names and think of ourselves as
ourselves
I wonder why with a name like Sam
Clemens which is a beautiful name why
did he feel the necessity of becoming
Mark Twain you know I don't that's a
good question but I don't think it was
unusual in those days it was sort of a
convention for writers to take pen names
it was a sort of a fashion
and he like that phrase Mark Twain there
was a river phrase that he learned as a
pilot it was two fathoms the difference
between dangerous water and safe water
for a steamboat and he always lived on
that margin so probably one reason he
took it he also was getting in trouble
with some people out in Virginia City
for the vigor of his knotty columns and
he wanted a little distance that's why
we have Mark Twain yeah I a brief
question about Twain as a either social
or political critic of the day what
would you have to say about American
foreign policy today and is there a
writer today adopting Twain's voice and
who might that be well the first
question it is happening pretty much as
it happened back then slightly different
slightly different scale and scope with
our adventurism in the Middle East I'm
not going to attack or defend that but
I'm going to tell you that that's
exactly what Mark Twain was seeing when
he came back from Europe and saw to his
horror that this great virtuous nation
that he loved he loved America and he
loved the 19th century he loved the
excitement of technology and inventions
and capital in the sense of progress
suddenly here was this country behaving
as did other predatory powers around the
world he did not like it he would not
like it today
the second question again I'm sorry Oh
an author today that that might equal I
can think of some people who in certain
ways are similar I think of Garrison
Keillor I think oddly enough of Woody
Allen who is doing parodies today in the
same way that's when Sam was writing in
the 1860s he was doing parodies of
women's fashion balls in which women
were wearing a brocade of broccoli and a
sash of mashed potatoes and thus attired
must be looked good enough to eat that
zany wordplay I think what separates him
from anyone now working today or really
after him is that no one else has
written an enduring worth of literature
to go with the fun and the political
satire
well Tom Wolfe well Tom Wolfe probably
comes as close from the literary side he
is RIT he is written he has
rehabilitated the kind of the public
novel the novel in which the characters
thrash out great events controversial
events abuses of power that are going on
today Wolfe is not exactly the same kind
of public presence that Sam was he isn't
the kind of towering figure of the
lecture circuit maybe the blog today he
comes close I don't think he can equal
Mark Twain as a humorist he's a powerful
writer and I admire him but he's not
quite there we're also from southern
Missouri do you think that you could
have written this book without having
experienced southern Missouri and New
England where are you from in southern
Missouri
we're from the Ozarks from those arts
okay I don't know why as I said earlier
I think the one thing that I have in
common with him is the understanding of
the call of the place that was Hannibal
was a magical little town and really
still is despite the hardships and
because it was small and isolated and
separated from the cities by great
prairies everybody in the town was
famous everybody was important every
event was epic and every street you
could burn into your memory as I have it
as he did so I think I understand his
relationship to place I've been to his a
home in Hartford several times how do
you think he got to Hartford in the
first place well he got there because
his publisher the American publishing
company had its offices there and the
the publisher named Elisha bliss had
written to him and asked him do you
think you could make a book out of the
Year sketches from from the Holy Land
and then he stayed because he loved the
place and in the elegance it I'm just go
ahead here's one
yes if you feel that Sam's a style of
writing change during the course of his
life god it's a wonderful question I
hadn't thought of it in those terms but
I I think as he got older a couple of
things happened I think through his life
he became more and more humane
I mean his humanity began to replace
this received racism that he brought
with him from Missouri he inherited his
mother's compassion and you know
sympathy for the dispossessed he always
had that so that humane las' matured and
became an important part in his writing
but the other thing was that he tried to
become a philosopher in his old age he
tried to write sort of the Socratic
dialogues that he broke philosophy what
is man it wasn't very good at that but
also the polemic that the political
writing he did as an old man he could
never have done as a young man at what
point did Mark Twain write the awful
awful German language and had he spent
time in Germany as a German teacher my
students have loved that he made a
terrible gas in Boston he when he was
asked to give a toast at Whittier James
Greenleaf Whittier 70th birthday party
and he decided to JISC it and poke a
little fun at the eminences that were
there Emerson on all those guys and he
went too far or at least he thought he
did he probably created the celebrity
roasts without knowing it but he was so
humiliated by what he thought was the
stony reception of the audience that he
went to Europe with his family and
stayed there for about a year and a half
and on that visit he traveled in the
Alps and heard the German language and
made great fun of it that was the
genesis of the awful German language
which I really love yeah yes hi I've
been reading and rereading his
autobiography the two volume set I was
wondering how much of it do you think is
fiction
the autobiography well that's what
nobody knows you could never trust him
with the facts and he kind of enjoyed
that fact himself he but truth and
fiction in the way didn't matter
to him but honestly did moral honesty
you could never go wrong you could
always trust him in terms of moral truth
as for what was real and what wasn't
he was always halfway into his dream
life and I like that about him I wish I
could get away with it but I can't I
want to thank all of you for coming and
for your great questions thank you so
much Ron powers wrote about Mark Twain's
Missouri childhood in dangerous waters
his latest Mark Twain a life is
published by the Free Press an imprint
of Simon & Schuster visit Simon Says
dot-com for more information